everything is politics nowadays you
notice that
everything is political uh
this is not political donald trump
his administration his cdc centers for
disease control
says celebrate only with your household
only with the people you've been with
only your pod it took about a pod now
only your family that's donald trump
president-elect biden's advisers say the
same thing
what is the last time you heard donald
trump's advisors
and joe biden's advisors saying the same
thing
right never this is the only
thing that i have heard them agree on
so this is not about politics this is
about just health
experts looking at those facts that you
just saw
it's going up anyway it goes up a little
bit
we're going to have a problem this is
not a normal thanksgiving
it was not a normal summer it was not a
normal labor day
it was not a normal memorial day it was
not a normal school year
nothing is normal because it's not
normal
you want me to act different than i act
normally yes
because it's not normal
well that's hard i know it's hard
it's all been hard
every day of covid has been hard
and thanksgiving is especially hard
i feel it for me thanksgiving was the
goal
that i was looking forward to when we
were going through all those covert
cases
i would say well when we get to
thanksgiving that's when we can
be together and that's when things are
going to be normal again
by thanksgiving by thanksgiving
and now we're thanksgiving and
things are not normal they're not normal
and it's sad and thanksgiving is the one
time it's family it's about family
i have one daughter i have three
daughters one daughter
twins and michaela
one daughter is in chicago i had her on
the phone
she was going to come home she's crying
on the phone the doctor said it's not
safe
for her to come from chicago because
even if you get a test then you have to
get on an airplane then you go through
the airport who knows what's going to
happen
so she's crying on the phone and you
know as a parent when your child
cries it just goes right through you
right you melt
just melts i have my mother
who is a senior citizen
she does not admit that she is a senior
citizen
my mother somehow became
younger than me in age i don't know how
she did that
mathematical equation in her head but
you talk to her
she's younger than i am
but she just doesn't understand it
she just does not understand it i had to
talk
to her last night she called me back
this morning to go back to the same
thing
i don't understand you haven't seen your
sisters in a long time you haven't seen
your
nieces you haven't seen your nephews in
a long time i don't understand it i
don't understand it and she doesn't
understand it
this is a thanksgiving 89 years old
never been to thanksgiving like this
in her life but that's the fact
and it is hard and it's hard to do and
it's so much easier just to say
we'll do it the way we normally do it
that's the easy way
we're gonna come over uh we'll be
careful
it's a mistake it's a mistake i wanted
to say to mariah
come home i said to mariah
i'll come pick you up that's a long ride
chicago
that's how bad i felt i said i'll come
pick you up but she said even if i don't
take the plane
then she's in a car with me for a number
of hours
and then she still winds up home in
front of people who she can infect
i didn't want to disappoint my mother
you know
89 years old she's thinking how many
thanksgivings do i get
right you start to think that way
but it's hard but sometimes
hard to smart the way i try to do it in
my
mind to help me sleep
is not a normal thanksgiving this is a
special thanksgiving
this is more special than the other
thanksgiving
because this is truly about giving
thanks
and honoring people who sacrificed for
us this past
year and there are a lot of people who
sacrificed to get us through covet
there are there are people who gave
their lives
to get us through covert there are
nurses who
died to get us through covet there are
doctors who died to get us through
covert there are police officers who
died to get us through covet
there are national guards people who
died to get us through covet
that's why this is a special
thanksgiving
and for that special thanksgiving yes
the celebration is different
but it is special and it is in many ways
more profound and more meaningful
than the past thanksgiving so yes it's
going to look different it's going to
feel different
but in here it's more special
it's more powerful than past
thanksgiving
i give thanks to all those essential
workers
who showed up for work every day
so we could stay home safely
think about that every day i'm standing
at a briefing sitting at a briefing
doing what i'm doing today saying stay
home
stay home it's dangerous don't send the
kids to school
stay home stay home stay home except you
a central worker
you have to wake up and you have to go
to work
why so we can stay home you have to
drive the bus
and have hundreds of people walking past
you
and put your life in danger you have to
drive the train
you have to be at the food store
to keep food on the shelves because if
we don't have food on the shelves you're
going to see panic
you have to show up at the utility
company
because the people flipped that light
switch and there are no lights in their
home and